[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولد القارئ قائد بشير مديره في احدى القرى
وسط جمهوريه موزمبيق الافريقيه
وكالعديد من اقرانه من ابناء الاقليه
المسلمه التحق بالمدارس الاسلاميه ثم بدار
العلوم الشرعيه فحفظ القران الكريم كاملا
وهو في الثالثه عشره من عمره قبل انتقاله
مع اسرته الى جنوب افريقيا لمواصله تعليمه
الثانوي ثم العوده الى بلده موزمبيق
للالتحاق بالجامعه الاسلاميه في عاصمتها
موبوتو
[موسيقى]
انا بدات يعني التعليم القران من من
القريه تسمى باجون
هذا يقول القريه في موزمبيق
ومكان هناك يسمى زمبيزيا زامبيزيا هذا وسط
تبع موزمبيق تعلمت هناك اني هذه
الكتب الابتدائيه ثم بعد ذلك
دخلت في المدرسه يقال دار العلوم
الاسلاميه
والمؤسسات هذه المدرسه شيوخ
مزمبقيين ولكن تخرجوا في باكستان
وحينما تخرج في باكستان رجوى على موزمبيقي
واسسوا مدرسه هناك والى الان الحمد لله
المدرسه يعني هناك مستمر
وبعد الاساتذه يعني توفي الله يرحمهما
والحمد لله انا حفيد القران هناك وكنت
تقريبا
ابن ثلاثه عشره حينما حفيد القران
وبعدما حفيظ القران
ذهبنا الى جنوب افريقيا
بدار الامم دارولوم زكريا هناك بجنوب
افريقيا هناك ايضا راجعت القران الكامل مع
الشيخ عبد الرشيد توبيا
هو الشيخ عبد الرشيد طوبيا وفي الحال هو
ايضا يعني يحفز الاولاد هناك في جنوب
افريقيا قال لهم وهذه الجامعه على تحت
الشيخ
شيخنا
سالوجي هو الرئيس تبع الجامعي هناك زكريا
وحينما حفيت القران يعني راجعت القران
بجنوب افريقيا بداعد التعليم
يعني تعليم اللغه العربيه والتعليم اللغه
الارديه والانجليزيه
والعلوم كلها يعني الفقه والتفسير كذا في
نفس الجامعه
وتخرجت الحمد لله رب العالمين الفلاته
بعدما تخرجت ذهبنا الى خروج في سبيل الله
يعني دعوه والتبليق وخرجت سنه وهذا كان
ذهبت ذهبنا الى بنغلاديش والهند وباكستان
هذه كان يعني للخروج
في سبيل الله ثم
رجعت حينما رجعت من هذه يعني من هذا السفر
كنت اول مدرس يعني في جامعه الاسلاميه في
المبود يقال جامعه انس بن مالك هم الذين
عزموني ان يدعون طلبوا مني لكي يكون هناك
اعلم الاولاد واحفذهم ايضا القران هناك
يعني كنت اعلم الاولاد واحفذهم القران
الحمد لله من
2005 الى 2007
ثم يعني كان في حاجه
للحفاظ لكي يقرا القران في شهر رمضان هنا
في البرازيل
وكان ذلك يعني شيخ يماني من برتغال كان
يسكن هنا في برازيل ولايه برنام والذي
يعني كتب هذه التسجيلات الاسئله وايضا
طلبوا من موزمبيق لكي يرسل بعض الحفاظ لكي
يقرا القران في شهر رمضان هنا في برازيل
في موزمبيق هناك كما قلت يعني بدايه
[موسيقى]
في الابجد مثلا هناك فيه هذا الترتيب تبع
اللوح
لان في الباديه كنا نكتب يعني الحروف
الهجاء في اللوح ثم نمسحها بعدما نحفظ
يعني هذا كنا الى الان وحينما زرنا زرت
هناك ايضا وجدت نفس الترتيب يعني يكتب
يكتب في اللوح ثم بعد ذلك تحفظه وتمس
وتكتب الحروف الثانيه الحمد لله ولكن
حينما دخلت في يعني في دار العلوم
الاسلاميه هناك لان هنا في المدينه يعني
غيرت الاحوال ان اكون نحفظ في المصاحف في
القران والحمد لله
والترتيب لحفظ القران هناك يكون في الفصل
تقريبا 15 نفر لكل لكل فصل ونحفظ عند عند
الشيخ وكان هناك الحمد لله شيخ الذي يحفظ
القران منه كان الشيخ عبد القادر عبد
القادر الله يرحمه وتوفي الله يرحمه اول
من حفظت مع القران كان الشيخ عبد القادر
وكان ايضا الشيخ داوود لازم هو توفي كمان
والان الحمد لله ما زال هناك الشيخ حسن
يعني لكل واحد له يعني له كره ليس كره
واحده الذي كل واحد ياخذ منه القراءه ولكن
نحن اول كنا نسمع دائما لشيخ منشاوي
والشيخ ايضا عبد الباسط
القديمه الذي كل واحد كل طالب يريد ان
يسمع صوته ايا ياخذ صوته ايضا والقراء اذا
تبع الحرمين الشريفين مثلا الشيخ عبد
الرحمن السديس وشيخ الشريم كما ان كنا
نسمع دائما اصواتهم والذي والحمد لله هم
الذين
اعطانا يعني هذه الفرصه لكي نسمع التجويد
ما خاصه يعني علوم التجويد كيف النطق
القران بالتجويد كذا تعلمنا منهم كمان
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]
الرحمن
علم القران
خلق
الانسان
علمه البيان
[موسيقى]
الشمس والقمر
بحسبان
والنجم والشجر يسجدان
[موسيقى]
والسماء رفعها ووضع الميزان
الا تطغوا في الميزان
[موسيقى]
واقيموا الوزن بالقسط ولا تخسروا الميزان
والارض وضعها
للانام
فيها
فاكهه
والنخل ذات الاكمام
[موسيقى]
والحب ذو العزف والريحان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان
صدق الله العظيم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تنوعت تجربه القارئ قائد بشير مديره
وتنقله بين موطنه وتعلمه اللغه العربيه
والارديه والانجليزيه اضافه الى اللغه
البرتغاليه هذه المهارات مجتمعه شكلت لديه
قدره فريده على التواصل مع الاقليه
المسلمه وهو ماهله للقدوم الى البرازيل
ومنذ العام 2007 وهو يتولد تدريس والامامه
وتحفيظ القران الكريم لابناء المهاجرين
المسلمين في البرازيل
انا تعلمت اللغه العربيه انا دائما اقول
ما زلت اتعلم اللغه العربيه لاني لا احسن
كما ان شاء الله تعالى ولاني انا دائما بس
اتعلم نحن كما كان شيخي ان الانسان لازم
ان يعترف نفسه انه
انه طالب ولا يزال ذلك ما يعني اي شخص
شخصيه يريد ولكن لازم ان يعرف انه طالب
العلم وانا ايضا اقول اني حينما يعني اعيش
مع اصحاب العرب مثلا اهل لبنان واهل سوريا
دائما انا اتعلم مع الشيوخ كمان ولكن بدات
التعليم اللغه العربيه بجنوب افريقيا
حينما دخلت في الجامعه
دار العلوم زكريا هناك كانوا اساتذتنا من
بنغلا من باكستان والهند هم يتكلمون اللغه
الارديه
وبالنسبه يعني لغتهم نحن ايضا تعلمنا لغه
لغه الارديه والحمد لله يعني اتكلم واكتب
كمان وافهم جيدا اللغه الارديه هذا اللغه
الهندي يا الهندي وفي باكستان ومع ذلك
يعني تعلمنا ايضا تعلمت اللغه العربيه لان
الكتب يعني الكتب الفقه وكتب التفسير كلها
باللغه العربيه اذا كان لازما ان نتعلم
اللغه العربيه حتى نفهمها في الكتب
والبلد جنوب افريقيا ايضا هناك اللغه
الرسميه هناك اللغه الانجليزيه
وتعلمت كمان لغه الانجليزيه هناك ولغتي في
موزمبيق لغه البرتغيز وجئت مع اللغه
البرتغاليه واذا اقول ان الحمد لله يعني
تعلمت الاربع لغات في نفس الوقت في نفس
هذا فضل من الله سبحانه وتعالى جئت
البرازيل
سنه 2007
انا كنت ادرس في الجامعه انس بن مالك
جامعه انس بن مالك هذا يكون في مبود عاصمه
موزمبيق كنت ادرس هناك واحفذه الاولاد
هناك يعني القران الكريم حينما يعني طلبوا
هنا في برازيل لان كان حاجه لبعض الحفاظ
لكي يقرا القران في شهر رمضان
وطلبوا منا هناك بمزمبيق بالنسبه للغه لان
لغه البرازيل هنا واللغتنا ايضا موزمبيق
نفس اللغه
واحسن لهم لكي يعني الناس كثيره من الناس
يفهموا ماذا يقولون يكون هذه العلاقه اذا
يطلبون من موزمبيق لان في الموزمبيق فيه
معاهد للتحفيظ القران
وكثير من المعاهد الحمد لله رب العالمين
وجئت هنا في الى برنا
في جامعه هناك جامعه فيصل وهذا يكون في
لندريلا اول ما جيت هنا في البرازيل الحمد
لله يعني
ذهبت الى هذا المكان لندرينا وقرانا
القران هناك في شهر رمضان يعني لم تكن
يعني قراءه مثلا القراء لا ولكن مرتل يعني
ترتيل
يعني للصلوات التراويح وبعدما
[موسيقى]
انتهينا شهر رمضان
قالوا ان فيه مسجد هناك ايضا في نفس يعني
في نفس الولايه في مسجد كانت تقريبا
مسكر يعني مغلق مغلق ليش لان لم يكن فيها
عالم لم يكن في شيخ اذا طلبوا مني لكي
اشوف هذا الجامعه هل يمكن لي ان اكون هناك
ان حتى يعني
يعني نحافظ المسجد ونذر الناس لكي نبدا
يعني بالتجديد هذا المسجد والحمد لله
حينما زرت هذا الجاميه الى الان الجامعه
يسمى جامعه برنفي مسجد السلام ذهبنا الى
هناك وكنت الحمد لله امام هناك تقريبا
بسته سنوات
وبعدما وكنت ايضا ادرس الاولاد في نفس في
نفس المسجد الحمد لله بعض الاولاد بداوا
يقراون القران كده
وابوهم يعني
هذا كان السبب الكثير من المسلمين هناك
يعني حتى اجتمعوا كثير منه ما بداوا يصلون
هناك وبداوا يعني ياتون بالاولاد وكنا
ايضا ندرس الاولاد القران ندرسهم اذا انا
مدرسه كان قبل ابن سينا كان مسجد الطريق
الايمان
اما هذا هذا المسجد نقول يعني اسسوها
الجاليه يعني اكثرهم من لبنان بل كلهم
نقول لان قبل ذلك يعني
البعض المسلمون كانوا اكثر بعض منهم اذا
كنا مثلا من فلسطين وفي سوريا كانوا
يعيشون في يعني في مكان مختلفه وهنا في
جنوب تبع سامباول وكانوا كثير اكثروا من
لبنان هم الذين اسسوا ونقول الان يعني
بالجاليه تبع
نحن نقول الان
لان هذا الجامع اسست
ب
71 واسسوا المسلمون الذين جاؤوا من لبنان
نفعل في كثير من الامور مثلا التدريب
عندنا مدرسه الاسلاميه هنا ابن سينا
وعندنا ايضا بعض الاولاد ندرسهم ايضا يوم
السبت خاصه يوم السبت لان المدرسه يا سمير
كل يوم يعني الاسبوع اما عندنا ايضا خاصه
يوم السبت نعلمه من القران لان بعض
الاولاد لا يستطيعون ان ياتي خلال الاسبوع
هنا ولذا نجمعهم يوم السبت وندرسهم القران
يوم السبت الحمد لله اما الجاليه كمان
الجمعيه عندهم بادوا الامور مثلا
الدروس يعني الشيخ ياتي الدرس خلال
الاسبوع يوم الثلاثاء يوم الاثنين ويوم
الثلاثاء ويوم الخميس يوم الاثنين عندنا
يعني الدروس الدينيه مختلفه احيانا يكون
السيره واحيانا يكون فقه واحيانا يكون اي
امور يعني حتى يستفيد الناس وكما يعني
تعرفون في الناس ياتونني خلال خلال خمس
سنوات يصلون هنا خمس صلوات ولكل صلاه له
درس الحمد لله رب العالمين
اقراكم شيء ان شاء الله تعالى من بعض
السور القران
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى والذي
قدر فهدى
والذي
اخرج المرعى
فجعله
رثاء احوى
سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما شاء الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى
ونيسرك لليسرى
فذكر ان نفعه الذكرى
سيتذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها الاشقى الذي
يسلى النار الكبرى
ثم لا يموت فيها ولا يحيى قد افلح من تزكى
وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا
والاخره خير
وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى
صحف ابراهيم وموسى
[موسيقى]
صدق الله العظيم الحمد لله رب العالمين
بالنسبه شهر رمضان هنا
نقول لكل سنه نرى يعني ترقي الاسلام هنا
في البرازيل خاصه لان كل سنه في كثير من
المسلمين يعني ياتون للسنوات الخمس وياتون
ايضا للصلوات التراويح خاصه
ونرى ايضا فيه كثير من البرنامج يعني في
المساجد مثل ايه الحمد لله ان القراء
الجاليه مثلا ياتون بالقران من مصر
ويقراون القران بعد بعد صلاه التراويح
وايضا فيه هذا يعني عند الافطار عند
الافطار هنا لكل جاليه له مساحا كبيرا
الذي الناس يفترون هناك ياكلون هناك بعض
الافطار وهذه نقول يعني والحمد لله رب
العالمين الان الاسلام ينتشر كثير هنا في
كثير هنا في البرازيل وايضا نقول ان كثير
من البرازيليين ياتون لكي يتعلموا يتعلم
الاسلام معنى الاسلام لان كان وقتا كان
زمنا الناس ما كانوا يعرفون ما الاسلام
حتى بعد الناس حينما يمرون هناك يقول هذه
بس كانه كنيسه للطرق لاحد الطرق اهل تركيا
ومكانوا يعرفون ما الفرق بين الاسلام وبين
وبين الاديان الاخر والحمد لله الان عندنا
بعض الكتب والاتحاد مثلا عندنا الاتحاد
هنا التي توجه الكتب توزر الكتب مجانا
وناخذون هذا الكتب ونوزع اذن عند
المحتاجين الذين يريدون ان يعرفوا الاسلام
نحن نعلمهم ونستقبلهم كثيرا ايضا الطلاب
من الجامعه وبعد الايدن الناس حتى يتعرفوا
الاسلام نستقبل امرنا وايضا الحمد لله رب
العالمين هذه الامور الذي نفعل في شهر
رمضان وفي وفي خارج شهر رمضان كمان الحمد
لله رب العالمين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات